شو تغير شو تغير فيك من من الالفين خلينا
نقول من حوالي 13 سنه او 15 حتى شو اللي
تغير يعني اللي تغير الحقيقه بعد التجربه
الاخيره تبع
تجربه الثورات
هو
مزيد من الاحباط ومزيد من الشعور بانه ما
راح اقول ما في شي بيتغير بس انه شروط
التغير
كثير كبيره
وكتير صعبه يعني غير متوفره يعني ما انا
متوفره ومن هم من السهل تتوفر
يعني مناعه بسيطه انه عشر ثورات
في العالم العربي اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
الفصل الاخير يعني لبنان العراق الجزائر
السودان عشر ثورات كلها فشلت
لما بتفشل عشر ثورات تباعا
بغض النظر عن انه بنقول هذا السبب هذا
السبب بس المشترك هو
يعني هذه اللي بيقولوا الصدف اللي بتصير
قانون اذا تكررت هالقد
المعنى في عطل عميق جدا جدا جدا
بوقعنا العربي يعني
باوضاعنا بامكانيه تغييرها بالسعي لشيء
افضل
فكيف انه الهزائم كلها واحد
الوقيع عم يعيشها فكريا وسياسيا بس بلبنان
تحديدا انا كلبناني عم عيشه شخصيا كمان
يعني موجود فيها صحيح